I had the pleasure of meeting Bob
Chapman and he approached me and says
you know I'm building a kind of company
that you talk about and my reaction was
I want to see it because I'm an idealist
I talk about what it should look like in
the ideal and I had the great honor and
pleasure of traveling around the country
and seeing many of the factories that
barry-wehmiller owns and I walked away
stunned I realized that I can no longer
be accused of being a crazy idealist of
what I believe exists in reality I saw
people who would literally come to tears
talking about their jobs I saw an
empathy and a humanity that exists that
I honestly didn't believe could be that
good and Bob's little experiment in
humanity has turned out to be not only
the right way to run a business but just
something absolutely beautiful to see